moi je voyage donc c'est le titre c'est
le titre de la chanson c'est aussi le ti
du bengale album le sol aznavour donc
douze chansons seront chargés goethe
encore ya une ambiance un peu walt
disney dans cette chanson je me trompe
je ne sais pas quand une bonne question
la question pas ouais ouais moyens non
si le problème si tu peux éviter de les
poser quand je parle c'est tout d'accord
mais qui parle tout le temps même temps
que je suis venue du parc ils ont fait
moi je vais donner ma gueule donc il
faut dire que les chaussées alors bien
sûr que oui savez que je suis là
alors je voyage celtique donc de la
chanson heures avec katia c'est aussi le
titre nouvel album de charles aznavour
donc douze chansons sur vos sujets
favoris la jeunesse la société l'amour
la nostalgie
une chanson qui s'appelle la critique
car vous dites on a beau dire au fond
que l'on s'en contrefout elle vous
détruit le moral et vous en fout un coup
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
j'en pense que j'en pense c'est que vous
n'avez jamais répondu sérieuse n'avait
jamais abordé le problème de la critique
vous avez jamais répondu ni par
téléphone et par courrier vous avez
toujours ignoré les critiques et dieu
sait si vous en avez eu je trouve ça
formidable qu'un jour comme ça vous en
vous en parliez en disant plus la vérité
c'est à dire non on s'en fout mais en
fait ça nous fait du mal quoi puis-je
est amusant de le faire aujourd'hui
pensent que vous êtes une vache sacrée
aujourd'hui faut dire du maintenant même
plus pour seule peut dire du mal de vos
charmes c'est sûr lorsqu'un peut-être
gérer mais j'avais envie de faire non
c'est bien ce que c'est pas amer en plus
vous dit on c'est vrai la critique on
les écoute quelque part mais une
amertume je sais bien il ya une fois
quand même où ça a été un peu de choses
c'est quand vous êtes fait l'olympia en
il y avait un journaliste qui avait
écrit pourquoi ne pas chanter avec une
jambe de bois
c'est vraiment méchant donc là vous avez
exigé un droit de réponse et la seule
fois dès hier sur radio luxembourg vous
aviez droit à trois minutes finalement
vous êtes resté neuf minutes
si vous ne pouviez plus la wii 1
d'autant plus je venais d'avoir un
accident alors là moi j'aurais pu la
voir et me faisait beaucoup enduré quand
même au début avec votre physique votre
voix vo vos chansons ah j'avais tout
comme trois mois c'est vrai la voix les
chansons disais que c'était pas c'était
pas populaire c'est devenu population 17
commercial
j'ai droit à tout un jour au crazy horse
et vous entendez quelqu'un qui dit j'ai
jamais entendu rien de si bons il était
devant moi j'avais envie de lui donner
un coup de pied dans la figure
mais c'est pas dans mes habitudes et il
ya un journal qui avait écrit maintenant
on laisse santé des handicapés
maintenant on lit plus allants les
critiques n'ont maintenant jantes et usp
et petrucciani a fait la carrière
concède en paix choses ont évolué
pour le mettre sur huit charles sinon on
va chercher alors sur les amours le 22
mai 2004 vous fêterez vos 80 ans au
palais des congrès ce sera la réussite
ou incroyable je réussir et même avoir
81 81 allez on fait à peine 60 ha par
l'audition est alors donc le 22 mai 2004
donc j'aurai 80 ans sur scène ce sera la
dernière de vos représentations qui
commence le 16 avril je le dis je dis à
tout le monde parce qu'attention lui sur
scène c'est trente chansons assez un an
à 80 avait pas de rappel pas de rappel
et 30 chansons s'ils veulent des rappels
je m'arrête à 25 mètres en appel elle a
peur de temps alors il est très secret à
vous et à vous êtes très très très
pudique vous êtes absolument
inattaquable parce que je n'ai
intéressant dans les journaux auxquels
je n'y suis jamais on a fait un petit
sondage sur vous jamais vraiment 67% des
français pensent que vous avez une
tortue 3 canaries une chatte par exemple
c'est crever je les ai par écrit honte
voilà 13 % des français pensent que vous
êtes chauffeur de taxi à tobrouk
comme quoi vous devriez quand même
beaucoup plus loin les mouches
demeureront à 6 4% des français trouvent
que vous leur faites penser à quelqu'un
sans qu'ils puissent retrouver le nom et
alors là 91% des français pensent que
vous portez et allumettes
non j'ai failli avoir un nom de regarder
la bague rendre ses vols intérieurs qui
permet charles
et denise est en cours voilà merci je
cirer les pompes hallyday gémissant
souliers à charles algérie bafia métier
quand messi les cheveux donc je tiens à
dire à vos amis téléspectateurs qui vous
connaissent mal c'est pas une perruque
vous avez fait de nous les aimons non
alors là oui c'est ça elle vient
désormais dollars ça vachement bien
marché revient mais la terre est bonne
si vous avez les cheveux un petit peu
long en ce moment c'est parce que vous
allez faire un rôle un c'est pas du tout
pour faire le coup parce que le père
goriot votre nouveau né a été offert par
par pias vous racontez ça dans votre
autobiographie le temps d avant paru
chez flammarion et avec gréco c'est vrai
que j'ai été les premiers mois je me
souviens vous faire refaire le nez on en
parlait à la maison c'est un événement
aujourd'hui tout le monde se fait
refaire le nez
non galabru l'a pas fait si vous étiez
les premiers avec gréco si c'était assez
scandale à l'époque ans maintenant bon
bah moi on l'apprend suppose que j'étais
inconnu
donc on a fait les cheveux on a fait le
nez et là le plus tard faisons la visite
avant
avant ne poussez pas que tu c'est à 70
il était petit charles aznavour avait
les jambes arquées oui déficient
immunisés marqué les gens imaginent
javel et jean louis xiii voilà louis
xiii alliés en vacances c'est tragique
berck à berck bayern ont déjà voté des
bières ben voilà non mais c'est une
jolie plage berck plage magnifique
magnifique vous avez survécu à tous à
vous avez survécu à la critique on l'a
vu les survécu à la guerre parce que
c'est vrai pendant la guerre moi je vais
partir mais que non mais c'est vrai que
vous étiez petit ont sagement vous étiez
souvent pas l'occupation il est souvent
menée à la kommandantur en vous prenez
pour m oui oui vous étiez emmené à la
kommandantur aider avec le nez que
j'avais je pensais pas pour un français
plus bel effet refaire en 45 c'est trop
tard oui alors vous avez survécu d'abord
à cause de ça ensuite vos parents était
sympathisant communiste il n'y a ni avec
manu chiant de tp moyles rouge donné des
coups de main oui ça c'était il venait
chez vous manoukian il veut nous après
les échecs
oui venez chez nous et puis sa femme a
été cachée chez nous et ensuite oui bon
c'est les amis de longtemps à voir avant
ont survécu à la kommandantur survécu à
la fréquentation de ce increvable non
mais c'est vrai alors vous quitté
l'école à l'âge de 10 ans et est à 15
ans ont fait du marché noir pour nourrir
votre famille parce que votre père était
engagé dans beaucoup de gens david
rageusement et là vous vendez du
chocolat des charcuteries et des débats
pour femmes oui à qui veut les vendait
aux boutons via le monde et qu'ils ont
manqué à ouvrir alors j'allais aux
portes de paris avec ma petite sacoche
comme ça et puis je proposais meba aux
allemands qui voulaient absolument en
acheter alors les hacher je me souviens
exactement du pij mende et tout s'est
toujours bien marque
un orque d'occupation mais je partais
vite parce que dès qu'on pensait la main
dedans ça filait alors un jour il ya un
riche arméniens qui décide de faire une
bourse comme ça pour aider des petits
arméniens les enfants démunis
vous vous retrouvez dans une école pour
apprendre la tsf enfin ça vous ennuie
énormément évidemment centrale a noté
sève brute de la lune voile a été réglé
vous emmerdez vous sécher les cours pour
aller au cinéma l'après-midi au music
hall où alors j'allais aussi voir jean
kissi avec des cours de comédie s'il
était dans l'assassin habite au 21
c'est ce que j'avais à dire je t'adore
l'on sait exactement je suis moi même je
fais des films la mancelle
et alors en 1941 vous rencontrer pierre
roche si vous faites un duo qui
s'appelle roche et aznavour départ c est
vous êtes embauché par tous voilà
c'était dans des boîtes de nuit
non mais beaucoup de remplacements aussi
et en 45 votre première chanson j'ai lus
et interprétés par georges ulmer est
alors mon temps là refusé sept jours
sans ça c'est incroyable ça meurt à la
fin c'est intéressant ça quand même vous
êtes vous êtes un jeune auteur
compositeur de chansons est en phase
yves montand qui compte déjà une star il
vous dit moi je suis d'accord pour
chanter de la chanson si elle a failli
meurt vous dit non non mais j'ai même eu
des des chanteurs très connus qui
voulaient y consigner les gens sont je
ne l'aimé pas jamais donné la moitié
d'une une oeuvre à quelqu'un qui n'a pas
travaillé dessus
comme je n'ai jamais parce que je
changeais une ligne pour vous une phrase
à dans une chanson d'un terrain
camarades je n'ai jamais dit je signe
avec un joli c'est bien la classe
charles haas et la classe et et mon
temps refusé à ça c'est encore pire que
tout je me voyais déjà
oui en dix ans il n'y a jamais une
chanson sur le métier qu'à marcher ses
fruits mais l'un las c'est excusable
parce que la plupart des gens pensaient
la même chose alors en 1946 francis
blanche vous présente
edith piaf c'était dans une émission ne
francis blanche à l on a connu bien mais
c'est pas lui qui me présenter c'est
elle qui elle vous a fait comme ça comme
salma fait comme dans la chanson à la
règle en pareil
et alors elle vous ouvre un petit peu
des portes de l'amérique vous allez
avoue fait un coup bol il vous décidez
d'aller chanter au carnegie hall à new
york pour le faire pas importer
personnes vous louer un avion avec 150
journalistes vous payez vous louez le
carnegie hall e3400 place vous chantez
en fait un tabac évidemment après tout
le monde il a réussi au carnegie hall
donc le monde entier vous appelle qui
risque rien n'a rien c'est assez fort et
oui
tant par les ondes les sens par les
anglais en lisant les textes à il a fait
patate à la dette mais il a des couilles
ça c'est clair vous êtes en de la marche
à sa dépend des jours aujourd'hui pour
des nuits exactement aujourd'hui ça va
aujourd'hui ça va très vite
vous croyez vous aurez droit à des
funérailles nationales non non non ou
alors en arménie a peut-être mais j'irai
pas la brancher un câble en france on a
amélioré avec le temps un mot pour le
gorille social est tout le problème et
c'est à bali a bâti un câble à montfort
l'amaury la mairie que vous connaissez
le lieu non c'est un cloître du 3ème
siècle
ah oui pour n'importe quoi et puis en
face les gens marchent à un peu plus
loin j'ai ces cibles g marshall il ya du
mou chez nous à ces six candidats oui et
je suis mieux que j'ai un bon j'ai fait
construire ce qu'il fallait
c'est d'ailleurs j'ai la folie de la
construction alors bien des regards sont
sympas important voisinage un pascal
scuteri ya des embrouilles après c'est
le bordel et pour démêler l'écheveau